let's bring in our Deputy political
editor Sam Coates now so Sam a big
political moment the resignation of the
Deputy Prime Minister
that's right and it's quite something to
think Anna that 48 hours ago it was
Dominic Robb sitting next to Richard
sunac at Prime Minister's questions that
was a moment see there's a symbol a
signal by many about how close the
Deputy Prime Minister was to the PM and
how hard it would be in the event that
the report that we we kind of all knew
was coming probably the next day uh that
how hard it would be to let him go and
all the way through yesterday clearly
Downing Street having to weigh up what
were quite difficult judgments because
it was absolutely clear from the delay
and the problem is it got the report
basically 24 hours ago now um it was
quite clear that what the report didn't
do was provide an absolute Smoking Gun
that would result in the automatic and
immediate dismissal of the Deputy Prime
Minister there was stuff to weigh up we
were told that this was a lengthy
document that it was very detailed it
had taken five months to assemble there
were multiple complaints that had to be
adjudicated on but there was a sense
that while we and being guided that we
might get a pretty quick decision from
the Prime Minister it was in the event
uh rather harder than that Dominic Robb
chooses to make a lot in his letter of
the fact that really only two complaints
uh were upheld and the rest uh were
dismissed
um knowing that knowing that there were
two complaints upheld and if if we do
get the Adam Tully report in full we'll
be able to see the details and I I still
think the plan is that we see it so when
it comes we'll be bringing you putting
it on that screen and going it through
it uh line by line it'll be interesting
uh to see uh just how much uh how bad
the behavior was uh how bad Adam Tolley
judged what dominic Robb did and uh will
be able to judge for herself whether or
not there was a realistic case uh for
keeping him uh clearly at points
yesterday Downing Street must have
considered whether there was a path to
keeping him that's why it would have
taken so long but here we are today with
the announcement of uh the resignation
uh although it's called a resignation
when you when you read the Lesser it
doesn't feel
uh like Dominic Robert is in any way
happy with the situation with the
outcome uh whilst acknowledging the
upheld complaints he says uh that
actually he says that the bar for a
billion complaint is effectively too
high and says that that's bad for
government that bad for society to be
set so high so I I suppose I'm I'm
questioning whether uh his resignation
letter really was a resignation or
whether uh he basically jumped because
he knew that he would have to be pushed
by the Prime Minister
um uh and and that kind of slightly
bitter tone rather reminiscent of the
slightly bitter tone in the Nadine zaha
we letter uh I think Will Shine through
and Spark a debate and that's probably
the politest word that we're going to
use uh but there's gonna be a debate now
amongst some of the Allies that we've
been hearing on Sky News uh for days
inside the conservative party who think
that Dominic Robb was the victim of a
politically motivated Witch Hunt uh from
uh potentially uh members of the Civil
Service younger members of the Civil
Service who didn't like his politics and
weaponized and HR system in order to get
him out of the jobs because they didn't
like what they were hearing now the
question is is Rishi Cena cable to
contain that debate cauterize that
debate close that debate down with this
resignation or are there some people
angry about what's happened here angry
uh that they will see the Civil Service
having fought and pushed a deputy prime
minister who at one point stood in for
the Prime Minister when Boris Johnson
was very ill it harder to push that out
but ultimately when you think of the
calculation for Richard we don't
understand it a little bit better as a
result of that letter from from Dominic
Robb Richardson was facing the
possibility if he wanted to keep Dominic
Raab in that job he was going to have to
explain why there had been two bullying
complaints harassment complaints upheld
against his Deputy Prime Minister but
effectively was still uh willing to keep
him in the job what he promised on the
steps of Danny Street about
accountability and responsibility and
respect and returning those sorts of
values to the heart of government when
he came in he would have had to done
that and face down the possibility of
perhaps victims of Dominic robs by
Behavior going public senior civil
servants who perhaps no longer in the
Civil Service being prepared to give
interviews and talk about what they
experienced while working alongside him
I think there was a lot that Richie
sunak was going to have to face down in
order to in order to keep Dominic Robb
in his job so perhaps that little uh
that slight tone of anger that tone of
bitterness some ironic given this is all
a discussion at received about a lot of
it about Dominic Robb's temper some of
that perhaps uh just uh a sparkling and
surfacing through in the way that that
letter is written I think it was uh
probably just quite hard in the face of
perhaps a sustained uh media appearance
from critics people who witnessed
firsthand and the fact that there were
two complaints upheld and and although
Dominic Robb may say the majority of
them are dismissed in in some senses you
know that there was a a finding that uh
that there was uh bullying in two cases
and and that is enough and and I think
in a lot of workplaces that would be
judged to be enough but the question is
do the conservative back benches agree
now Richard cynak is lucky that this
didn't land four months ago or three
months ago this is this is a report
that's been taking that's taken five
months in the making because the
political conditions for Richardson were
very very different back in January
February uh his position much less
secure however in the last couple of
months we've seen he's Richie sunax
fundamental political position improved
dramatically after the success of the
Windsor framework domestically uh after
some of those foreign trips where he
stood alongside Joe Biden in San Diego
making a bit of a mark on the world
stage uh bringing together the
conservative party uh back in
Westminster even doing something of a
deal around small boats with Tory Rebels
just uh 24 36 hours ago all of that
probably means that although there will
be sympathizers of Dominic Robb there
will be people who feel that he's hard
done by people perhaps those who came
out in the on the airway based on Sky
News yesterday the day before say that
they hadn't seen Dominic Rob bully they
thought he treated everybody with
respect uh uh uh that actually the
internal criticism for uh for this
decision uh is relatively minimal I know
people around Dominic Ram now some of
them in the last 24 hours have been uh
briefing pretty bullishly talking about
being lawyered up even though the law
doesn't really focus feature in this
process talking about a fight to the
death that he was prepared to uh to make
again uh perhaps an unfortunate analogy
in the context of what we really uh
really talking about but I do know other
people who are around Dominic Raab who
for some weeks of effectively to me been
acknowledging that a positive outcome
for the Deputy Prime Minister was was
highly unlikely and that uh he was
almost certainly going to have to fall
on this sword as a result of the
cumulative nature of the complaints and
the stories uh some of which we've heard
in the media uh and and no doubt when we
get that document shortly uh we'll be
able to peel through it uh line by line
we'll we'll we'll get the the full cast
of it
um but there is something it's got to be
honest of a national conversation going
on at the moment about exactly the
things that Dominic Robb talks about in
his letter there is particularly in the
um light of the dismissal of the former
head of the CBI Tony danker there's a
discussion about how one person's
workplace etiquette standards culture
the way they talk to other people the
standards that they demand might be
acceptable but another person might not
find that acceptable and I think um it's
quite interesting that Dominic Robb
leans into that discussion which will no
doubt feature in our politics in the
days uh to come as people try and get to
grips with uh people from sometimes
different Generations but not always
setting different standards um
approaching issues different ways being
more sensitive uh than others and uh
there will be some in the in the Tory
party who will be tempted uh to say that
what's happened here is uh the
derogatory term for Whitehall used by
some Tory MPS which is the blob has won
this time by uh serving up a chorus of
complaints about the Deputy Prime
Minister a figure that intrinsically
they didn't like and that the Prime
Minister has given in to that and that's
the issue here so I think that there is
a discussion to be had politically where
people try to minimize the political
Fallout but in the end Rishi sunat must
have decided that even if uh Dominic
looks like he resigned although he looks
like he didn't want to resign from the
letter in which he announced his
resignation uh that he I think Richie
sunac will have decided uh that the pain
of keeping him outweighed whatever the
potential benefit it's work for
impressing perhaps one flank of his
party and effectively standing by his
Deputy Prime Minister
um it is it has to be said you know
people's political careers are judged by
the public in the round and this will
obviously be a very important part of
his uh of his record as uh will be the
um standing in for Boris Johnson when
Boris Johnson had covered but of course
one of the things that might have made
it easier to wave goodbye to Dominic
Robb today were the circumstances in
which he departed from the foreign
office in 2021 they weren't they weren't
pretty you'll you'll remember in that
summer there was the evacuation of
Afghanistan NATO uh uh pulling out of
Afghanistan the U.S and the UK as well
and I think in that uh in that period
Dominic Robb was on holiday uh Dominic
Robb didn't uh uh go back to the foreign
office oversee in person and ultimately
uh
um Boris Johnson decided to demote him
now you can see on your screens that we
do
that have the letter from Dominic Robb
that's the one uh where you do see the
sort of just that slight sense of
bitterness and anger uh coming out uh
just to read some of it that you can see
on the screen uh he talks about um he
feels Duty bound to accept the outcome
of the inquiry by the way uh viewers of
skogies will know that he made the
pledge to resign if there was an
accusation of bullying to Sophie Ridge
on uh on Sunday so he had committed
publicly to resign if there were
allegations of bullying that were upheld
in this inquiry if you look at paragraph
three on your screen it says um the
report did dismiss all but two of the
claims leveled against me I also believe
that it's two adverse findings are
flawed and set a dangerous precedent for
the conduct of good government you know
what um now what that means is that the
next question for Richie sunac is does
he believe that the eminent Casey who
spent five months doing a report into
Dominic Royal's Behavior issued flawed
judgments that's quite an incredible uh
attack line from Dominic Rob who of
course himself is a lawyer quite an
incredible attack line against uh Tully
and the report that he's spent five
months yeah totally as a man uh of some
standing in the legal profession it'd be
interesting to see whether he agrees
with Dominic Rob interesting to see
whether uh Rishi selac agrees with
Dominic Raab uh who makes uh levels
quite an aggressive accusation about
adverse findings which are flawed in his
language and a dangerous precedent for
the conduct of good government well
there are people that disagree with that
there are people in private who who do
talk about how it was difficult working
with Dominic Robb the received senior
civil servants who wouldn't let junior
staff alone with Dominic Raab according
to reports certainly that I've heard
Dominic Robb still in this letter uh
insisting uh that he uh does uh uh uh
sort of behave professionally at all
times
it's an interesting letter because in
many ways it suggests that he both
accepts and doesn't accept the findings
simultaneously which is why this all
throws up but the fact that he's
resigned probably minimizes some of the
pressure on the Prime Minister but it'll
it'll be interesting to see uh quite how
he uh he the Prime Minister uh answers
the the challenges and the questions
posed by Rishi sudax by Dominic Ralph's
letter there now the letter goes on uh
ministers must be able to uh exercise
direct oversight with respect to senior
officials over critical negotiations
conducted on the behalf of the British
people otherwise the Democratic and
constitutional principle of ministerial
responsibility will be lost and that is
how Dominic Robb frames the way that he
conducted himself in government and of
course there are other accounts of how
he uh behaved Infamous examples from
2018 where he was appointed brexit
secretary suddenly turned up in Brussels
to the consternation of the negotiating
group not clear uh what gains he made
but uh uh there are in Whitehall
memories of moments like that where uh
some believe that there wasn't uh good
behavior now in this letter what's
interesting is Dominic Robb goes on to
attack those people who quote unquote
leaked those episodes now he basically
says it is unacceptable for members of
Whitehall members of the Civil Service
to effectively talk about his behavior
he he thinks it is a bad thing that the
media got hold of accounts of his
behavior uh which he contests and thinks
that that's unacceptable
um but what's interesting about this is
that really we wouldn't be where we are
today without the reporting not just on
Sky News uh but on the guardian and
other media Outlets which brought to
light in quite Stark terms the fact that
there have been formal complaints it was
the media coverage that resulted in
Dominic Robb having to ask for an
inquiry into himself by the um by the
Prime Minister ultimately done by Adam
Tolley back last November so I suppose
in one sense yes Dominic Robb can regret
uh the fact that civil service or
proxies for the civil servants or
representatives of the civil servants uh
we won't know who uh did reveal details
of Dominic rail's Behavior but however
much he might regret it the truth is he
would probably still be Deputy Prime
Minister today if that wasn't the case
so an attack on leaking an attack on uh
uh the standards that he thinks should
be maintained in the workplace but
according to the accounts that that I've
heard that that there are there have
been quite difficult episodes
um some people might characterize it as
controlling he would say uh that it was
only exacting standards uh uh the the
sort of General theme that that I think
uh that when he talk to a lot of people
that have worked with Dominic Robb that
that does surface quite repeatedly is he
very much was a politician who liked
doing things uh in a very specific way
uh to to quite a fine degree he liked
exacting ways for documents to be
prepared uh he was very hot on timings
he was very hot on presentation uh he
was very hot on how he was treated now
he will argue that was appropriate for a
senior Minister who's trying to run a
government Department uh to behave
others clearly disagreed and we await
the details of the two cases of conduct
that Adam Tolley the Casey believes were
inappropriate and that's the and that
that really is that the nub uh of this
letter uh and the reason why Dominic
Robert said he's going to resign uh and
that um he has accepted his fate and
done what he promised to Sophie Ridge
that he would do uh a few weeks ago and
resign if that report uh found uh that
there was bullying but Westminster never
stand still and so we uh uh uh so we uh
uh you can see the door of Downing
Street there I'd expect some activity uh
a little bit later today uh with uh
perhaps a new replacement as Justice
secretary and then there's a decision
for the Prime Minister as well whether
or not he does a like for like
replacement of the Deputy Prime Minister
job because that's a title that comes
and goes in British politics Dominic
Raab was initially at the point that
Boris Johnson came in given the chart
the title of first minister of State
okay and then when Boris Johnson demoted
him in 2021 from the foreign office to
the justice department uh he gave him
the Deputy Prime Minister job as a
consolation will that job title be
handed out today or might it just
disappear for a little but that we
should find out a little bit later